Ron is with us in st. Louis hey Ron
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show you know
our good afternoon how the heck are you
better than I deserve sir how are you
well I'm better than I deserve probably
okay so I'm a recent graduate of FPU
last fall and I've knocked out several
debts I'm on my last one and it's got a
serious negative connotation to it and I
just I hate that I have it there and I
want to talk to you about it and I'm
excited to hear what your plan of attack
would be on it okay so okay so this is
actually two debts that are combined one
was a medical and one was through for a
car loan that that that got lumped
together and got sent to the collection
agency an attorney handles this now it's
okay so I don't know if these he works
law and then he does collection agency
on the side or what but okay so this
thing was how did they get a lump
together a car loan and a medical well I
don't exactly know I know that it went
to one collection agency they were
handling both of them and then it got
sent to another collection agency okay
so but they were from separate lenders
they weren't together and that year I
got combined they're not combined
they're two separate accounts with one
collection agency okay right but he has
color he has combined them both because
I've asked you know because I paid
enough to where I thought one of them
would have been paid off and they said
no these are together it's all just one
total so if I if I have time I want to
break down each one so I have one
question on the medical one it was like
a thousand dollar debt and when I asked
and then these are old I mean when you
talk about having student loans sitting
around as long as a pet you know my
first few debts that I paid off one was
a student loan from 2001 and one was
from 1997 so hold is this debt this debt
is roughly ten years old okay so he's
bought the debt as a debt buyer is
what's going on or he's representing a
debt buyer and they have chosen to
combine the debts and so one was a
thousand and one
was how much the other one was for a car
that during my it completely
irresponsible financial days I let the
insurance lapse because I had the loan
on it the bank contacted me and said if
you don't put insurance on it we will
force place it on there for you right
well me being stupid I said okay well
it's fine I'll just keep making my
payments and they're gonna tack the
insurance on the end well I don't know
how much longer it was but I got into
the car accident totaled the car called
the bank they said nope you don't have
any insurance on this car I said no wait
a minute you told me you were going to
force place it well they backed out of
that and they stuck me with with with
the remainder of the balance which was
about nine thousand dollars so because
you have a ten thousand you have ten
thousand dollars an old bad dad how much
have you paid off with the other debt I
paid off about eight thousand dollars on
the other debt so this is my line the
step there was this collector right how
much have you know I don't nothing how
much we pay down the ten thousand
dollars with this collector here's the
thing i-i've made minimum payments over
the past ten years not with not with any
kind of religiousness okay so this thing
was Court judgment was entered for
$11,000 over the past ten years this
thing is ballooned up even with minimum
payments being paid this thing has
ballooned up over almost a seventeen
thousand dollars
do you have any money I have my thousand
bucks in the bank I don't pay this guy
another dime don't pay him another dime
and and start saving money as fast as
you can save money this is the last one
in your debt snowball and once you save
up six thousand dollars in Colin offer
to them as a settlement in full I pay me
to get past the gatekeeper at his office
okay
that's okay just call them and say I
have six thousand dollars when you want
some money call me and hang up well what
if what if he what if they take me to
court and garnish my wages no they could
but if you call them like everyday and
say I have six thousand dollars when do
you want some money call me and hang up
oh by the way I have six thousand
dollars have you heard the rumor I've
got six thousand dollars you want some
money call me and hang up they
eventually will call you and you will
get on the phone but you're dealing with
a clay
you're dealing with a debt buyer and
what they are is a machine you're you're
a widget in a factory this is a on a
scale of one to ten this is a ten in
your life on a scale of one to ten in
their life it doesn't even show up they
don't even care this is like your like
fingernail clippings okay they don't
give a rip and so you just need to stay
in their face but you got to get some
money first before this comes life you
need two settlements if you know if you
don't settle this as a lump sum it's
never going to go away you can pay
thousand dollar payments the rest of
your life they're gonna keep adding crap
to this I just make this up as they go
these debt buyers are crooked as a dog's
hind leg man I just make up crap and say
yeah I mean you were gonna say something
about saving money on the side and what
I was prepared to do is make my minimum
payment and then keep stashing like no
don't make any chairman don't make any
payments stop making payments okay and
just say I'm gonna pay you I'm gonna set
up with you and a lump sum but you got
it you got to come up with like six
thousand dollars really really fast well
I always think nobody's gonna have to be
more than that probably he probably paid
a nickel on the dollar for that ten
granny probably paid five hundred bucks
for this that's well that's what he's
got into it plus his man-hours and his
overhead and whatever else crap but you
know what do you make a year well I
officiate some what do you make a year
I'm about 40 okay cool just a simple now
just save up you need to work as fast as
you can get on it get on a tight budget
like we teach have a big garage sale and
you need to scrap up six grand as fast
as you possibly can because sometime in
the next hundred and twenty 180 days
he's gonna get pissed again and go back
and do something you're you're gonna
fall out of his little factory over
there into the judges lap again and you
need to have the money before then and
start offering him about 25 or 30 cents
on the dollar cash on the Barrelhead and
you can settle this get it in writing
because you can tell these people are
lying if their mouths moving I'm telling
you this is a filthy business you're
dealing with filthy but you're the guy
and paid the bill either in ten freaking
years so it's time to get with it and
get this thing out of your life but you
can pay him minimum payments and mess
around with this the rest of your life
and you'll never it'll never be gone you
need to settle it settle it as a lumps
settlement and offer him six thousand
bucks eventually in you know ten twelve
conversations they eventually will take
it but you're just gonna have to stand
firm this is what I have this is all I
have my financial adviser told me not to
give you anymore payments to give this
as a lump sum this is all I have
I'm sorry I can't do anything else my
financial adviser told me and and
because she I just did and so you're not
lying and and just tell you know just
stand your ground stand your ground you
can keep adding to the lump sum if you
want to as you keep saving money but
when you get up five or six thousand
dollars start making them an offer you
might start at two but just keep adding
to it but just make them cash lump sum
offers and stop making them payments
because they've added they they've
quadrupled this thing they've added so
much crap to it not just simple interest
and not just late fees they've added
legal costs that aren't even there
they've added all kinds of stuff to this
it's it's an unscrupulous business
believe me they're just hoping to get
something out of you and you owe them
something so this will settle it get it
in writing in writing or don't give them
any money and don't give them electronic
access to your checking account this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]